quite generally the familiar just
because it is familiar is not
cognitively understood the communist way
in which we deceive either ourselves or
others about understanding is by
assuming something as familiar and
accepting it on that account with all
its pros and cons such knowing never
gets anywhere and it knows not why
subject an object God nature
understanding sensibility and so on are
uncritically taken as great for granted
as familiar established as valid and
made into fixed points for starting and
stopping while these remain unmoved the
knowing activity goes back and forth
between them thus moving only on their
surface apprehending and and testing
likewise consistent seeing whether
everybody's impression of the matter
coincides with what is asserted about
these fixed points whether it seems that
way to him or not
section 31 begins with this kind of
funny play on words that Hale is making
in the German which doesn't translate
that well into the English and it turns
on this this distinction between the
pecan that which is familiar that which
we've gotten to know and the air Conte
the what I've you know got here from the
Millar translation has cognitively
understood a Kenan denotes in this case
a different mode of knowledge a more
thorough and more rigorous way of
understanding something than the sort of
surface level superficial gliding over
its exterior familiarity that's being
translated as as the Canon mecan't yeah
and so he says the familiar just because
it is familiar is not understood it's
not adequately understood why not well
you know as Hegel just sort of relying
on the truism that well when we're
familiar with things we don't pay that
close attention to them or is he after
something that goes a little bit deeper
that's really the latter he says the
communist way in which we deceive either
ourselves or others about understanding
deceive ourselves about understanding
what does that mean so we deceive
ourselves about the fact that we have
understood that's one way we can also
deceive ourselves about what it is that
we are understanding the object of the
understanding and we can also deceive
ourselves and others about what this
process of understanding would entail
understanding or coming to know so he
says the Communist way is by assuming
something as familiar so where we go
wrong is
assuming things that what we know or
what we want to know here falls within
the realm of what it is that we already
know what it is that we already
understand but it's just something
within the realm of the familiar now we
can begin from that that unshakable
starting point which actually when we
start looking at it turns out to be all
full of holes all full of you know
things that really ought to be shaky
that ought to be shaken up a bit so we
assume that what it is that we're trying
to to make sense out of whether by
ourselves or in conjunction with others
is already something that we know on
some level that we can make sense out of
on some level that we have the basics
down for and now it's just a matter of
sort of filling in the gaps filling in
the content we've got the outlines we
just need to color in the parts so he
says this form of comportment assumes
something is familiar and then
acceptance on that account with all its
pros and cons it's in German head and
hair rated you know saying this about it
saying that about it
such knowing never gets anywhere and
here's where he says something really
interesting this kind of knowing never
gets anywhere and it doesn't actually
know why it doesn't get anywhere by
confining itself to what it thinks it
knows it cuts itself off from the
possibility of actually understanding on
a deeper level where it's going wrong
and so we can see this in a lot of
different examples and experiences
ranging from everyday life to you know
academic philosophy or really any other
academic topic or really anything that's
in the media or that journalists play
around with that's exactly
what he's talking about in this case
he's talking about you know big
metaphysical topics like subject and
object God nature understanding
sensibility and so on uncritically taken
for granted as familiar established as
valid meaning starting points that we
can just kind of say well we all know
what this means we you know we can begin
from here and then they're made into
fixed points for starting and stopping
so what they do is they provide us with
these kind of anchors well we know about
this so once we know about that we can
get from here to here and then from here
to here here here and pretty soon we've
got a nice network of everything that we
can make sense of it I apologize for how
messy this is getting but this is what
the the understanding when it's working
within the realm of the familiar starts
to do it takes these things as fixed
points and that's awfully convenient but
the question is is that really true and
is that gonna get us anywhere do we
learn anything when we assume that we
already know it and it's just a matter
of sort of you know putting things in to
the proper places or do we learn when we
actually have the experience of being
shaken and saying oh whoa yeah I
actually don't know as much as I thought
I did I I'd better take a close look at
this well whether it's you know personal
relationships or one's you know
understanding of money in the economy or
politics or philosophy you know the
highest metaphysics we actually need to
get away from thinking that we already
have a solid sense of what it is that
we're talking about and this is where so
much academic philosophy goes wrong you
know people begin by using whatever it
happens to be at the time here's here's
this one example substance do
well we all know what that means right
Descartes was a substance duelist
Spinoza is not a substance duelist he's
a monist
and which of these is correct you know
which of these is the way in which we
ought to look at the world or look at
free will or look at you know I mean
even though you use the word free will
do you actually know what that means is
that something that you you're already
familiar with if it is then you probably
don't cognitively understand it because
it's a complicated matter which ought to
strike us is something uncanny something
strange something that we need to
explore some more even if parts of it
are in fact familiar to us through our
own experience through our own
discussions about it you know it's not
to say that we have to begin from no
starting points whatsoever but we need
to be prepared as we go from topic to
topic to topic to be shaken up a bit
to have that familiarity banished and
actually say to ourselves all right
what's here that's what phenomenology
means phenomenology means attentiveness
to what presents itself phenomena what
presents itself to us not what we think
is already out there because we're more
comfortable with that because that's
more familiar to us because we'd like
everything to be nice and tidy and easy
and safe when we make progress it's
generally by seeing just how strange
things are seeing how much is actually
going on beneath the surface that we
didn't realize was happening and that
only happens when we de familiarize
ourselves that's part of what's going to
happen in Hegel's phenomenology he has
one last parting shot here he says
apprehending and testing likewise from
this point of view consists in seeing
whether everybody's impression of the
and coincides with what is asserted
about these fixed points whether it
seems that way to him or not
so what Hagel wants to get us away from
is a kind of cultural at this point in
time consensus about well this is really
what philosophy is doing if we adopt a
historical perspective on philosophy not
only one that includes Hegel's you know
past but one which places Hegel within
that past and encompasses some of the
reactions against Hegel and all sorts of
other places where philosophy has go on
we can see that this is indeed something
that people do quite often in philosophy
in political science in religious
studies in all these different
disciplines they make these big
assumptions that well you know
everybody's doing it this way this is
just the way it's done nowadays nobody
takes that stuff in the past seriously
and Hegel would be the guy if he was you
know brought up to date saying well wait
a second are you sure about that
why don't you take a close look yeah
what it is that you think everybody just
includes in their discourse that's
probably enough said about that because
where we're gonna go from here what the
question we have to ask ourselves is
great so we defamiliarize so we shake
things up a bit now what's going to
happen
the analysis of an idea as it used to be
carried out was in fact nothing else
than ridding it of the form in which it
had become familiar to break an idea up
into its original elements is to return
to its moments which at least turned out
in the form of the given idea but rather
constitute the immediate property of the
self this analysis to be sure
or only arrives at thoughts which are
themselves familiar fixed and inert
determinations but what is the separated
and non actual is an essential moment
for it is only because the concrete does
divide itself and make itself into
something non actual that it is self
moving the activity of dissolution is
the power and work of the understanding
the most astonishing and mightiest of
powers or rather the absolute power the
circle that remains self enclosed and
like substance holds its moments
together is an ant is an immediate
relationship one therefore which has
nothing astonishing about it but they
had an accident is such detached from
what circumscribes it what is bound and
is actual only in its context with
others should attain an existence of its
own and a separate freedom this is the
tremendous power of the negative it is
the energy of thought of the pure eye
death if that is what we want to call
this non actuality is of all things the
most dreadful and to hold fast to what
is dead requires the greatest strength
lacking strength beauty hates the
understanding for asking ever what it
cannot do but the life of spirit is not
the life that shrinks from death and
keeps itself untouched by devastation
but rather the life that endures it and
maintains itself in it it winds its
truth only when in utter dismemberment
it finds itself it is this power not as
something positive which closes its eyes
to the negative as when we say of
something that it is nothing or is is
false and then when having done with it
turn away and pass on to something else
on the contrary spirit is this power
only by looking the negative in the face
and tarrying with it
this tarrying with the negative is the
magical power that converts it into
being this power is identical with what
we earlier called the subject which by
giving determinate nests and an
existence in its own element supersedes
abstract in the immediacy that is the
immediacy which barely is and thus is
authentic substance that being or
immediacy whose mediation is not outside
of it but which is this in this
mediation itself
what happens after we have broken the
spell the charm the seduction of
familiarity
we're in able to look at things in a new
light does that mean that we just now
see it as a whole as some sort of block
and we see it under a different aspect
than we did previously when it was
familiar over here Hegel says no one of
the things that weren't able to do when
we get away from seeing things as the
familiar and therefore not really seeing
them is we're able to engage in analysis
and analysis this is a term that people
use quite frequently as a matter of fact
this is something that we ought to get
less familiar with and actually look at
what it means so when you analyze
something it doesn't mean to criticize
it it doesn't mean to put it back
together it doesn't mean just to
summarize what it means is to break it
down or to break it apart into its
constituents so to analyze this piece of
chalk you know if we're doing a chemical
analysis would mean to break it down
into the chemicals that compose this
compound compound means that it's put
together parts and so you know calcium
and then whatever else is in this carbon
some other things as well that would be
a form of analysis when we're doing say
an analysis of a situation we're looking
for the key constituent elements in it
that make it what it is so there's a lot
of different levels on which we can
carry out analysis there's a lot of
different ways in which we can analyze
but in every case the act of analyzing
means taking something angles going to
talk about an idea in this case but
taking something and breaking it down
into its parts
now some people are not that comfortable
with doing that because they like to
think you know holistically or they you
know they they don't want to reduce
things and Hegel's very receptive to
that so as a matter of fact one of the
big problems with with modern philosophy
was this reductive notion that if you
can just break things down into their
parts by understanding the parts you
understand the whole in Hegel would say
well that's and that's not actually true
so why in a moment but it is important
to be able to break things down you know
for instance in grammar you do in fact
gain something by being able to diagram
sentences diagramming sentences it was a
form of analysis into parts of the whole
you know of an entire expressed relation
of thought that's what a sentence is so
in this case Hegel talks about the
analysis of an idea in part consisted in
D familiarising that idea and then
breaking it down into its its elements
to break an idea up into its original
elements he says it's to return to and
there's a key term throughout a galleon
philosophy to return it to its moments
this is something I do want to spend a
little bit of time on at this point and
I'll stress this at multiple points in
other sections as well when Haley uses
this word moment what he means is that
each one of these things is not an
independent entity that has its full
meaning in and of itself but rather than
it is a part of a whole he talks in
terms of moments not in terms of like
moments of time but rather you know like
think in terms of things balancing each
other you know comprising an entire
whole I'd like to get away from spatial
metaphors let's use for example the
Aristotelian definition
anger which is a quite complex
definition as far as emotions go the
most complex limit aerosol gives you he
says that anger is a type of pain that
it's also a desire designer for what for
a parent retribution in response to some
perceived or apparent sliding carried
out against oneself or those connected
with one he's got all these things
rolled into it those are all elements
those would all be moments of it because
if you take desire by itself desire by
itself is not anger
it's got to be desire for this in
relation to this directed this way
that's you know for example one way in
which anger is different than hatred for
Aristotle anger wants to see some sort
of retribution some sort of revenge some
sort of you know hurting in response to
the other person whereas hatred wants
it's a desire to merely see the other
person be gone altogether to be
eradicated to not exist it's a for there
to be a world in which they play no part
these elements as moments then allow us
to differentiate wholes apart from each
other and we'd make a mistake if again
if we think that we can break everything
down as to an elements and them you know
that's that's all we need to do in order
to understand things but it is important
to carry out this to this kind of
analysis so he says this analysis to be
sure only arrives at thoughts so in the
case of an idea what we have is elements
are smart slots and they are themselves
familiar fixed and inert determinations
so we can carry out this process of D
familiarization at the level of the idea
or at the level of each of these
elements and
this may take a lot of time this
actually may take a lot of work it may
not be something that's simple to carry
out but if we want to fully understand
the thing that we're trying to come to
know trying to come to make sense of and
especially if we want to understand our
own relation to it then we have to be
willing to defamiliarize these and what
that means he's saying is that they quit
being things that we just take for
granted they quit being inert fixed
points or determinations so he says what
is the separated and not actual is an
essential moment it's only because the
concrete does divide itself and make
itself into something non-actual these
are not actual not in the sense that
they don't have any existence that they
don't have any any being but that
they're not fully what they ought to be
they're not yet revealing themselves as
what they what they really are the
concrete divides itself makes itself
into something not actual this part of
the process that's what makes itself
moving so he says this activity of
dissolution is the operation of we
understand it the understanding is a
faculty that makes human beings what
they are this is part of our mental
equipment that allows us to do the sorts
of thinking processes the sorts of
making sense out of things that we as
human beings generally take for granted
because we're doing them all the time so
he says this is the power and work of
the understanding the most astonishing
and mightiest of powers or rather the
absolute power the absolute power why
because it can break anything down it's
really you know quite amazing when you
think about the fact that human beings
are a being within this entire world and
we're the being that can interrogate the
rest of being and make it tell us things
and make it do things for us animals of
course can do this plants can do this in
their own way but they're very limited
we have this incredible plasticity that
allows us to adapt our minds to all
these other things and then to turn
inward on ourselves or to look at
society or to look at relations between
human beings and to make that an object
of study as well so he says the circle
that remains self-enclosed and like
substance holds its moments together is
an immediate relationship one which has
nothing astonishing about it but
something new happens one of these
elements will pick this one over here he
says an accident as such detached from
what circumscribes it what is bound and
his actual only in its context with
others so at the first spot the first
moment not in that moment in the first
phase this only has its meaning its
existence as part of a whole and then
it breaks that it becomes independent it
asserts itself over and against the rest
of what originally gave it its meaning
its function its purpose its entire
reality he says that what is bound and
actual only Nets context with others
should attain an existence of its own
and a separate freedom it attains a
ability to determine itself because
that's of the essence of freedom he says
this is the energy of thought of the
pure eye so we're not talking about
something like chalk you know the
elements of that separating out in the
calcium becoming soft overhead then
deciding for itself
I'm not going to bond with the carbon
anymore I'm not going to take that we're
not talking about that what we're
talking about here is a person we're
talking about human consciousness we're
talking about distinctively human being
in the cosmos and he says this is the
energy of thought of the pure eye
meaning the if the the ego the pure eye
in the sense that Kant was was talking
about the the unity of that perception
at this point we don't have a human
being that has these determinants
character characteristics of you know
wearing this this jacket and being this
tall and being 43 years old and having
chalk on my hands or anything like that
we're talking about something that's
more abstract but underlies every every
given consciousness so he says now he
makes a major shift he since death if
that is what we want to call this non
actuality is of only all things the most
dreadful why is he talking about death
here
well because the understanding and death
are somehow connected with each other
and that matters for any individual
thing which would assert itself against
the rest of existence this is what he's
calling the power of the negative this
is a very important passage because of
that he says death if that's what we
want to call this non actuality is is of
all of the things most dreadful and to
hold fast to what is dead requires the
greatest strength lacking strength
beauty hates the understanding for
asking of her what it cannot do but the
life of spirit so again we're not
interested in what's beautiful what's
familiar all those sorts of things we're
interested in charting out the
development of consciousness the
development of spirit over time it says
the life of spirit is not the life that
shrinks from death and keeps itself
untouched by devastation so you might
say if you want to follow Hegel out
you've got to be willing to throw things
onto the table you've got to be willing
to you know be befuddled for a while to
be upset to be frustrated to have to you
know work and labour and perhaps when
you're engaged in the labour not see the
promised land over there where
everything's going to be a-ok and
everything will make sense because
that's part of the process as well we're
going to see this come up at numerous
points in the phenomenology this need to
be willing to feel that one is forsaken
in order to progress further to risk
everything so he goes on and he says it
winds its truth only in utter
dismemberment it finds itself and that's
part of what's going on throughout the
entirety of the phenomenology of spirit
it is this element which is trying to
make sense out of everything else has to
find itself scattered in everything else
Andrea
appropriate that bit by bit by bit
achievement by achievement to itself and
do this not only in a sort of
experiential way but also do this in a
cognitive way so he says it is this
power not as something positive which
closes its eyes to the negative not as
something that that just is and then
unfolds itself but something that has to
make choices something that has to
persevere something that has to and
again he uses this term tarry with the
negative it has to linger for violin
with the negative spirit is this power
only by looking the negative in its face
and tearing with that this tearing with
the negative he says is the magical
power this is about the only place
you're going to see Hegel talking
romantical powers because you know he's
not one for just saying well it's magic
he wants to understand all of this and
that means this process of breaking
things down and then ultimately putting
them back together again after some
parts have become separate and have you
know become conscious this is the
magical power that converts it into
being and he says this power is
identical with what before we called the
subject shouldn't even raise freedom
there but freedom is inherent in the
subject the subject now real realizes
that it is the one who actually carries
out the analysis it is the one for whom
ideas have being it is the one that can
actually cognize these elements as
moments of a greater whole and now the
question is how is this sub this subject
going to comport itself going to make
sense of itself in relation to these
other things that it becomes to know so
he says this power is identical with
we call the subject which by getting the
terminus and existence in its own
element the subject is what creates
space within itself for ideas ideas
exist in our minds in our experience
we're coming to realize ourselves as
subjects in the course of this
phenomenology so he says this supersedes
abstract immediacy the immediacy which
barely is and thus is authentic
substance that's what the the entire
phenomenology is about trying to do
become authentic substance that being or
immediacy whose mediation is not outside
of it but which is this mediation itself
that's the last phrase in there we
should think about what that means so
instead of having my mediations outside
of myself and saying I'm related to
these things or I'm related to death or
I'm related to the abstract
understanding the mediations are part of
what I am now Hegel doesn't spell this
out at this point but one of the things
that I've been thinking about lately in
relation to this is that's part of what
actually allows us our freedom the fact
that our mediations that which which you
know make us you know the kind of things
that we are are not outside coming in at
least some of them but are things going
on within ourselves over which I don't
want to say we have control but in which
we have some sort of contribution to
make